[Music]
in fake friend news a lot of those yeah
st. because you know why because when
you work in entertainment people want
true they wanted the jump of your
followers and you don't know who your
friends are or not unless they do some
kind of sacrificial thing where you go
okay you proved yourself yeah or
opposite happens is they blow up and
then they stop talking to you have
numbers submitted by Monday night a teen
who pushed her friend off a bridge might
face charges I saw this video that she
was [ __ ] up my yes I'm saying my face
charges why are we even talking about
this about the getting in trouble part
it's the you saw the video it went viral
it was pretty [ __ ] up I want to see oh
you can see the person getting push yeah
Oh buddy who films I was I'm surprised
that they didn't get in trouble because
that was a video that was some like
[Applause]
takes place in Washington but it feels
good to be exclusive do it oh I see she
died she died like face-planted I see
what is how did she die she died
I see why it's a my I see you at some
yeah kajori in that environment you're
in that environment you're gonna jump
anyways but the other person did push
you into dangers way just like what I
wonder what happens in our body that
like we're flying in air that we like
want to run for some my god yeah that's
true what is the kick feet cartoon I
might try to get balance it's an aerial
coping mechanism yeah like you kill the
Li you don't have any ground to run her
few were like [ __ ] go usually arms
going did she live though cuz then they
come she did she did but look at her
breath
what is she parallel that's why I was
last she did a roll runner yeah like
that was a hard fun yeah and it was like
I was a [ __ ] up push the whole time
going down she's like that [ __ ] shirt
I think she was getting in the perfect
position for a nice sweet belly flop cuz
yeah yeah but it was like really far no
but then it's like more than a belly
first after pictures of her [ __ ] cut
up and all that
if someone's pushing you you can't aim
like where you want to jump to that's
what's [ __ ] up when she came back
bogus you like [ __ ] you Jordan Jordan
wait no you're kidding me
Jordan was the victim oh god no yes
that's weird
it seemed like Jordan ish behavior yeah
but you know what I mean you know you
see you know George Jordan's the victim
the girl the victim yeah like that group
Taylor was the girl and we wouldn't we
wouldn't do this [ __ ] to each other wait
is Taylor a girl the one that pushed was
a girl I thought was a boy no that's a
big girl dude it reminds me of the story
where the bride got pushed into a pool
and then paralyzed forever and she never
wanted to say which one of her
bridesmaids it was the one that did it
cuz she forgave her she Mia was an
accident but don't push your friends
right next to the pool and you know
their phones on on to me like I miss
those days like when we didn't have
phones and you can just freely do not
miss phones are waterproof I've done
that to you and you got [ __ ] pissed
when those times where you're like don't
you [ __ ] [ __ ] she misses when she's
the bully sure nobody misses getting so
you're not my friend okay you don't you
gotta push him in the pool document
friend that's why everybody laughed
because they [ __ ] understand no
you're not my friend
they're my friends you're not my friend
oh yeah that's all you got people in the
boys
you're not my friends we'll be quiet I'm
confirmed you know your friend now yeah
oh I thought we were all friends no you
should you were still in the dog yeah
you didn't Ronnie too much no it's
because you called her out she didn't
like that I like being a dog huh all
right yeah we're in the doghouse she's
16 years old
she's 16 she looks like she's like 28 no
work done
don't get without much work though and
she reminds me of that one Blair she
looks like she has lip fillers and she
she's put yeah I think she's pouting
yeah I mean it just looks like cause
usually that facial structure doesn't
happen until all your baby fat drops off
when you're in your late until you're a
geezer do they live in LA Washington be
googling face surgery much holy [ __ ]
I've been watching a lot of botched oh
yeah and then this is Taylor the girl
who pushed her weight see look they look
identical
quite so lady they don't look that units
yeah it looks like the tailor was super
tanned and like had different hair
they'd look like little girls in the
videos yeah she looked huge on the video
this girl the pusher I don't watch it
again let's watch it again that's what
you cuz I think they both look like the
same person
yeah they do I thought it was like a
football player yeah they look like she
don't like a big girl and that girl
looks old look look at how she looks
light as hell you see
oh my god oh [ __ ] she pushed some Oh Oh
God that is crazy Ikes
that's like six stories this is the
bridge up here she saw that I kind of
want to live around there why would you
push your friend off that that looks
like a nice fishing place funny what
it's a pool that's like right there no I
know but that's the meme is that it's
funny her eyebrows are still nice don't
even know she's lucky she didn't drown
if she was that injured in the water
yeah she's so lucky she suffered five
cracked ribs a bruised esophagus and
injured trachea oh my god air bubbles in
her chest get a blouse off again holy
[ __ ] probably extremely black it looked
like she landed like Oh buddy the water
is like cement when it's that but I mean
you're just like you're in shock she
said that she kind of blacked out midair
but because she got so scared it's like
guess like this shock like I mean
imagine being pushed from that you're
gonna do that ensel yourself I wouldn't
wanna do a survivor
into a survival cannonball I think I
would want to know what you're supposed
to do if you're like somehow but
douchebag friend in the mid air you have
to try to put your you have to try to go
like this but you're her friend pushed
her so hard it was like yeah she was
just trying to like figure [ __ ] out yeah
remember when you were a kid and you
peed yourself and you get like a rash
that's what that looks like very much
peed in the bed all the time I peed in
the bed I thought he's talking about
like well you know like some kids that
you start walking around there's like a
wet spot you have acid I would drink a
lot of acidic juices like all normal
kids they're acidic juices what's
innocent what's jealous a joke about
that just the way you've described it is
so like like a scientist
well I have a medical background like
just say hi see or whatever the [ __ ] you
drank like Sunny D I was drinking off
random those
this [ __ ] Koger yeah yeah orange
juice is an acidic juice kogure we have
the same one that's a Costco bath Jordan
you see that's the pusher right stuff
like that I thought the bear was holding
her hand looks like it yeah
is that her before or after the seems
like it's after cuz she's wearing a
medical grade oh my goodness she's not
that [ __ ] up yeah and this is uh oh
and then also they're reporting that the
pusher she just doesn't give a [ __ ] like
she doesn't care what happens and she's
been going to good parenting
very good parenting she's been party
like this is after that incident and so
she's just going out like nothing
happened
how dare she go to those county fairs
they did say that she did text Jordan
saying like hey I'm sorry but that
everyone around her is saying like that
was not genuine at all like she just
does have a fat some people dread it
overcompensate that way because they
don't want to feel bad you know like
[ __ ] yeah I don't give what I don't care
this is that's not cool I'm [ __ ]
cannot call their kids so Jordans the
one that's saying that like well I don't
want to seek revenge on her or anything
like it's fine she I know what happened
dance because Jordans way prettier than
Taylor until there's like you [ __ ]
took the guy I told you I'd like and
she's younger it's you
Jordan's younger and you see yep but
they look exactly the same they do maybe
Jordan's trying to look like Taylor
let's create a backstory trailer I like
trailer better the trailer pushed Jordan
so Taylor's the bad the bad guy bad guy
she looks like a bad guy right there and
their children Joker she does yeah I
mean they're just reporting like the
Anna's [ __ ] up she doesn't really give
a [ __ ] cuz she did that's her friend cuz
her friend could have died oh yeah dude
the lady the wedding lady who got pushed
into the water and got paralyzed
the lady who pushed her should be her
slave for [ __ ] life yeah like she
should have to like change out our
bedpans and all kinds of stuff and like
walk like walk around everywhere when
you when you hit water from a high
distance it's like hitting concrete you
gotta do
there's people those people that fly off
a jet skis and they break their arms and
stuff to just from like skimming that's
cuz when you when you make impact it's
like hitting concrete Nicky said that
already
I'm sorry I'm sorry there was another
one where I think this girl got thrown
from a roof into a pool and in she was
trying to sue but it was cuz uh she was
like a hole from one of the dan
Bilzerian groups uh and then people were
saying like we're just trying to make a
lot of money because he's famous so she
deserves to go I wish people would be
like you oh yeah yeah I know I know
like if you're hanging with Dan
Bilzerian we all know that you're there
for the money what I want to talk about
I heard as a very term personnel yeah
right totally that's what I heard too
I already else you think that would [ __ ]
you up in court if you say like I got
hurt and I'll use their for the money
and I'm like yeah so you think that
would hurt it should if the defense
maybe if it's a jury thing and they
don't like your person yeah what yeah
what hurt it because you're always
people are always suing for not what the
real issue is you're not the weird thing
about so it's like emotional distress or
like this other thing it's never like
you just didn't make me feel good yeah
you know they don't become really sue
funny anyway they gotta find the list
thing go I guess these three things are
the clothes it's like when you try to
get your marijuana [ __ ] clinic card
yeah just like well I'm kind of tired
and I'm always hungry or I need to be
hungry yeah remember in Nicole Smith she
and she married that guy for his money
obviously we can't calm a guy who was a
grandpa well totally exactly who she met
she married that guy who was like
halfway out of out of in the other in
the next life yeah and weeks away from
death yeah and even after she lost the
court case where she would have gotten
like two hundred million or whatever the
[ __ ] she still it was like she was still
in court because she was always like no
no I really did love him swear to God
maybe she did love him Steve
oh please love just knows no boundaries
yes you don't love a raisin okay give me
a [ __ ] break
I don't like raisins
[Music]